we had seven people send me slides um so
I've just written them down in some not
in some order um and I've taken all your
slides and concatenated them into a
single PDF so that there's less uh
issues with Transitions okay and also
maybe so everyone doesn't have to get
miked up each time just use handheld mic
um okay so I think you know seven time
seven people times three minutes each 21
minutes we have an hour for this so
maybe after that we could also do some
lightning
introductions um so after the last
person mad gadiri I I'm sorry if I said
your name incorrectly um each person
could just say name where they're from
and very very briefly like one sentence
or two like what you know something you
work on that you think would be
interesting for other people to hear
about okay so let's get
started
[Applause]
I
working awesome hi everyone uh I'm from
the University of Melbourne um I've been
in the US for a couple months so I've
got basically one slide and then a
picture so what do I work on I
occasionally I work on I very rarely
work on actually sketching I sometimes
work on streaming Els mostly what I've
worked on throughout my career I keep
coming back to is this problem of
correlation clustering um I'm trying to
get a photo of venat Moses and me it's
20 years since our fox03 paper and we're
sort of celebrating that um but I did
work on correlation clustering in
streams with a bunch of people one of
whom is one of the organizers of this uh
and we had a lot of fun turning um Moses
algorithm with with n and ala into sort
of a multipath streaming I've also
worked on parameterized versions of
correlation clustering and connected
them with other sort of clustering
paradigms like spasis cut and uh
modularity and so forth I'm I quite
enjoy and what I'm currently working on
quite a bit is covering in streams um
first started thinking about this
actually the external memory context
with um Howard carof and gra corod when
they at AT&T Labs because people that
actually did want to solve large set
cover instances and it wasn't clear how
efficient sure gre's poly time but poly
time is when you're working on large
sets data sets poly time isn't
necessarily what you want so we came up
with something that was quite efficient
in practice and then later with the Met
chakra body showed that in some sense
it's sort of the right thing to do um
theoretically with lower bound more
recently uh Andrew and um ho published a
lovely algorithm uh that ran it in a
very small space and then we were sort
of accelerate with a student we
accelerated it and then looked at what
happens in random order streams um the
other topic I kind of enjoy is what
Andrew kindly called corrupted searching
where you're um you've got you're doing
binary search with errors and and what
can you do there and first I got
interested in it because my colleagues
work on Optometry algorithms uh but we
did a result sensitive uh version in
Isaac 19 and then more recently the
unbounded setting so have I hit my three
minutes yet give a minute you're only a
minute and a half then oh really want
too fast man I was like get it all out
there okay um apparent um I I should say
that I did was love fun experience I had
early in my PhD I'm not a lower bounds
person at all but I enjoy working with
lower bounds people uh so we had some
fun back in 2001 uh working with a met
who's been one of my mentors and
colleagues for a long time um I was just
going to show this diag I thought I'd
even have five seconds to show this
diagram but I've sort of Gone Too Short
doesn't matter you can talk to me later
um so we're working on random water
streams where we sort of I had this
another excellent Master student and we
sort of reparameterized this uh in a way
so that you could
um you you could um apply you could
substitute a submodular maximization
algorithm into this situation that
worked for random order streams and then
um run that for Max coverage knowing
that in a sense the size of what you had
to store was somehow the size of the
largest set so we sort
reparameterization and this could run in
space order K squ well order Tilda case
squared Andrew looked at this straight
away and it he who suggested we work on
this and Andrew looked at this straight
away and said case Square that's
terrible I can get you that K in about
five minutes so um let's see what we can
do with that Andrew Andrew and I and mid
are doing some fun things in this area
okay I'll save the time for someone else
[Applause]
thanks as
[Music]
well
uh I'll just I'll just tap the
keyboard okay uh my name is Daniel uh
postto at Stanford and statistics
Department this is going to be close
work with prti who's here in the
audience uh so sketched pseudo inverse
what do I mean by that sketched Matrix
inversion where where do you see this
for example in sketched Ridge regression
so say we sketch the features in a rid
regression optimization we have this
sketch Matrix S we apply to X on the on
the right uh we have a nice close form
solution which will be useful for the
analysis uh but
classical type of sketching results
would say if s has a nice embedding
property and the sketch size is
sufficiently large then we're going to
basically recover the optimal solution
as if we hadn't sketched at all uh the
question that we wanted to answer is
what if the sketch size is not
sufficiently large uh big surprise you
you're not going to get the solution as
if you hadn't sketched at all but you
actually can say what you do get if you
can understand uh this Matrix which we
can do using random Matrix Theory and so
what we show is an equivalence of
sketching in the sense that if you send
Q and P to Infinity proportionally to
each other then almost surely these two
matrices the sketch pseudo inverse and
an inverse uh with a different
regularization mu instead of Lambda
these two matrices will be equivalent in
a certain sense and there's some mapping
between mu and Lambda that is determined
by some spectral properties of both s
and the data
Matrix so what does this mean this means
that any way that you linearly uh
measure either one of these two matrices
you're going to get the same value in
the ASM totic limit such as if you just
pick out One Singular element you have
the same value for each element of this
Matrix uh another way of thinking about
this is as a conditional expectation
conditioned on uh the matrices that does
not include the sketching Matrix uh and
using that perspective you can also
think of higher order moments and things
like that which we can evaluate uh and
derive from this relationship so we Pro
this for IID type sketches like IID Gan
but just bounded moments but also using
a notion from free probability Theory
where if the data Matrix and the sketch
are Asm totically
free so just to demonstrate this really
quickly uh so if the data Matrix say
sample coari has a diagonal structure
zeros on the off diagonals it has zeros
ones and twos on the diagonal the we can
actually compute numerically what this
value of mu should be for a given Lambda
PL those on the dotted lines the
diagonals indeed do converge as the
dimensionality increases towards these
values and the off diagonals all
converts to zero this is for an IID type
sketch which gives a particular value of
mu uh but we also know the relationship
for orthogonal sketch which has
different spectral properties and so has
a different value of mu which I've
marked it here in red we can apply this
uh to other practical sketches that
maybe we don't have this guarantee for
like a count sketch but we find that it
matches exactly like a gaan sketch
whereas the subsample would randomize
hat our transform exact is exactly like
an orthagonal sketch not really
surprising but if you use zero padding
because you're not near a power of two
on your srht uh you actually have a
significant amount of spectral
Distortion and this changes the value of
mu that you obtain so uh when question
we would like to raise is whether um uh
embedding properties like JL are
sufficient for a fre such that we could
actually apply these types of results
thank
[Applause]
you hello I'm Michael and I'm a PhD
student from Oro University under Casper
uh and I'm currently visiting the fury
Department here at Berkeley into the end
of December so what I'm excited about
and have done some recent work on is
dimensionality reduction that you also
heard about yesterday so dimensionality
reduction we have some points at Q which
is at most of size n and then you have
some approximation error and then you
want to preserve the par wise distances
of all the points inside this set q and
as we saw in the first talk yesterday uh
this dimensionality reduction technique
is often used to speed up algorithms so
this is going to the smaller embedding
space and then solving the problem down
there so we want fast embeddings of the
vectors so yesterday we saw the
classical jail construction that's H
fully then scussion Matrix and the
embedding time of M Vector here is K
times D so can we get better embedding
times while still preserving this
embedding Dimension K the answer is yes
there's several constructions one of
them is a spar jail transform where you
have a sparse Matrix so Z out some of
the entries and you have plus minus
signs on the nonzero entries and here we
showed recently that you could actually
do the embedding time now of one vector
in this uh amount of time where it was
previous known that you could do it in
epsilon log one/ Epsilon uh so we showed
that if n is much larger than D then you
can actually do this faster in some
cases another way of doing J JL faster
uh is using the fast JL transform where
you have a construction of three
matrices a diagonal matrix a Hadar
Matrix and then a sparse Matrix the
diagonal and then Hadar can be
calculated fast and pre-process the
vector such that The Spar Matrix in the
end can actually be even SP spaser than
just doing a regular Spar Jail uh and
here we recently showed uh that the
previous analysis of the fast jail was
actually not tight you could tighten it
further we show on the matching lower
bound uh yeah so that was it thank
[Applause]
you uh hello I'm Leen uh I'm second year
pH student uh at MIT mathematics uh
advised by John ker uh while my research
focus is to use sketching to speed up
various uh optimization processes
including convex and non-convex
optimizations so some of my recent Works
including um to solve the low rank
Matrix uh Matrix completion problem
using alternating minimization and
sketching and uh we show that given a uh
M byn Matrix uh with rank K and some
incoherent assumptions uh we can solve
The Matrix completion problem in time uh
Omega times K where Omega is the number
of entries you sample uh from The Matrix
and um some other works including to
solve the semide definite programs in
streaming settings using interior Point
method and we show that you can do that
uh using a very novel and a simple
sketching approach uh in scroll and
passes uh m square space uh and um the
wrong time actually achieve
state-of-the-art uh when the number of
constraints m is in certain regimes uh
of the dimension end and um some other
works including design adaptive
sketching data structures for faster
convex optimization so this one actually
kind of generalizes um the talk given by
tho in the previous work workshops where
he shows
that using differential privacy noises
is you can actually reduce the number of
data structures uh when you're designing
the data structures that are adaptive uh
that are robust to Adaptive adversaries
and we show that you can actually
further generalize these ideas uh when
your output is not like a real number
but a vector and then we show that you
can actually uh use this clever idea to
speed up some processes in empirical
risk minimizations semi-definite
programming Etc and some other
applications uh in machine learning
including how do you design fast data
structures to efficiently train or
parameterizing new networks and how can
you use sketching to uh improve the
communication efficiency of Federated
learning Etc yeah thank
[Applause]
you hello everyone um my name is daniil
vanov I'm a PhD student at Arizona State
University I mainly focus on
optimization non-convex distributed and
uh more General problems of rational
inequalities it's a general problem that
generalize game theoretic problems
multi-agent uh reinforcement learnings
and optimization so uh now I'm really
interested in um the Vias assumption
that you can um consider for veral
inequalities problem and how to how to
find the fastest method for such we
assumptions for vice so if you want to
talk about me about that uh yeah I'm
here thank you that's
[Applause]
all hi everyone I'm Justin I'm a fourth
year PhD student at MIT working with
pendic and I thought I'd take take this
time to tell you about sort of three
problems that that I'm interested
in so the first is the following okay
I'm going to give you K distributions
which are sort of shown in this top top
row here they're going to be discret
distributions over one through n and
you're going to get samples from one of
them and your job is to tell me which
one you're getting samples from so this
is a problem that's been studied a lot
in terms of the sample complexity the
number of samples you need to to solve
this problem but uh with some
collaborators uh we've been looking at
sort of a different question which I'm
I'm very interested in which is sort of
a structures question for this problem
so if I I give you these sort of K
distributions ahead of time can you take
polom time to pre-process them and then
uh answer this question of which
distribution you're getting samples from
both with a sublinear number of samples
so fewer samples than you need to learn
the distribution and also sublinear
query time so less less query time than
you need to actually go over each of the
distributions so that's sort of one
question that and then I'm interested in
and I'd be happy to talk
about another is this following stream
question so you're given a stream of
elements uh and the goal is to
approximate how many elements appeared
exactly one time exactly two times three
times and so on so I give a sort of a
classic uh literal streaming example
let's say you're sitting on the bank of
a stream you see some fish walking by
you see a salmon and anroy and anroy a
Cod and antroy and a salmon again and
you have to tell me that you saw you
don't have to tell me exactly how many
times antrop appeared but you have to
tell me that you saw one fish once one
fish twice and one fish three times okay
and so uh I've been thinking a lot about
sort of the tight space complexity for
different Notions of error for
approximating this distribution of
frequencies of elements that appear in
your
stream and sort of a last sort of meta
um algorithmic question that that I've
been interested in is this field of
learning augmented algorithms or
algorithms with predictions so the idea
here is you're running some algorithmic
task on similar inputs day after day and
maybe you can learn some information
about the inputs uh that you're seeing
and can you use this learned information
to design better algorithms so to hear
more about this Su will be giving a talk
on on some work that we've done uh later
this afternoon so that's it for me and
be happy to to chat with any of of you
about any of these problems
thanks hi everybody I'm mad I just
started a post at MIT about a month ago
this is based on a joint work with
Richard ping and my PhD adviser s Shalo
um I'm going to talk about the bit
complexity of linear programs very
briefly um and to just give like a brief
overview of my research in the past few
years I've been focused on numerical
linear algebra and its applications
ranging from tensor decomposition to
causal inference so let me start with a
question uh let's say you have two
algorithms algorithm ones need an A
Squared Min uh addition subtraction
division multiplication operations and
the algorithm to need into the 1.5 of
such operations um which one do you
think is
faster this
says what's that numers yeah so it it is
a trick question it depends how you
represent your numbers it depends on how
big your numbers are it depends on the
order of these operations and so on so
let me ask you a second question how
fast can you solve a linear system ax
equal to B
um so for people who uh have seen like
linear algebra stuff you can use
Kramer's Rule and um it turns out using
Kramer's rule some P addic some random
some U uh number to stuff you can solve
this in N to the Omega times the bit
complexity of the Matrix plus the bit
complexity of the vector Over N so one
can use this to solve oh yeah and N to
the Omega Omega is the matrix
multiplication exponent
and one can use this to solve linear
programs in N to the Omega plus half
times some log factors which depends on
the radius and error and stuff um and
how how can you do that it essentially
bus down to that um ipms can solve uh
LPS in about a square root and
iterations and um the next question you
might ask is why is this interesting um
uh wasn't there like a work that did
into the Omega time a few years back um
actually that was like the number of
arithmetic operations and it was over
exact
arithmetic so uh it is mentioned that
you can do this with L bits large L bits
where uh dmax is the largest absolute
value of the determinant of any
subsquare Matrix but the point is that
for most matrices and by most matrices I
mean over random matrices with high
probability this is n to the Omega plus
one so let me finish with this result
which says that you can replace that uh
L with that log factor and why is this
good the reason is that um this uh Kappa
like the condition number of the Matrix
is uh polinomial in N with high
probability of random matrices but the
determinant is exponential and for all
of the like the two results that I
showed you um this there are like uh
settings like there are problems where
uh the coly s brand gets like into the
Omega plus one while ARS get gets into
the Omega or into the Omega plus half
and uh the main tool here is uh we show
that inverse maintenance is backward is
stable and the error increases only
additively so you can use this for
pation as well and get the same
results that's
it thanks to all of our lightning talk
speakers and eyeballing it it looks like
we have more than 30 people in the room
I think and we have 30 minutes left for
lightning intros so try to keep your
intro under a minute like ideally 40 SEC
30 seconds okay and I'll start with Tony
I know Tony wanted to also plug yes
something maybe we'll uh we'll we'll
like snake around this way and then go
to the other side and snake
that thank you very much sorry but I
didn't use up all my time before H just
wanted to advertise Isaac 2024 in Sydney
next year we don't have a lot of
theoretical computer scientists in
Australia but Julian mro and I and
people like clont Canon are trying to
build that up um I think the admission
would be about June next year it's a lot
of fun and you can come to a place where
it's warm in December instead I know
it's a fairway from a lot of places but
it'll be a lot of fun and help us build
up something new thank
you
Sor
oh what was the inro of my name where
you're coming from and the I guess you
said yeah I already said that but like
the to say like one problem I really
care about is like uh doing invers
maintenance over like pcts like the
first result I mentioned is like without
like inverse maintenance so I really
care to see like how we can do invers
maintenance over
P hi everyone my name is Alexander I'm
software engineer from
yaho and um with colleagues of mine we
are working on sketching algorithms
implementing them as um library in
Apache so this is Apachi data sketches
so we would love to implement your
theoretical results and work with you to
improve whatever we have and Implement
new stuff thank you very
[Applause]
much hello everyone I'm Lee roads uh
also at Yahoo and uh working on the data
sketches project which is an open source
project at at Apache and our mission is
to U translate a lot of the theoretical
L literature into sketches that
Engineers can actually use uh every day
and uh for solve U common big data
problems hi everyone my name is Charlie
I'm the the third of the Yahoo
contingent here uh I'm a scientist
working with the team but the research
problems I'm interested in are like how
you can use sketches for applications in
machine learning or privacy but I work
very closely with these two
on yeah I'm based in London so come out
here for the
week um I'm Cameron MCO I'm at UMass
amst and I mostly work on randomized
methods for linear algebra but with a
lot of sketching I've been recently
interested in a lot of sublinear methods
and linear algebra on structured or
unstructured litery so I'll give a talk
later today about that
thanks I am Samson so I started my first
semester at Texas Anum University um an
area that I've been working in recently
is adversary robust streaming algorithms
where the data may not be independent of
the internal randomness of the algorithm
and I guess one of the cool results I've
seen lately or I guess I worked on was
its surprising connections to the
sliding window model which is also a
different streaming model
hello everyone my name is Rael Meyer I'm
a pH student at NYU working with Chris
MCO uh I study a lot of also randomized
algs for linear algebra I often count
how many Matrix Vector products are
required to solve some linear Al problem
and I'm interested in understanding how
many like structured Matrix Vector
products are required to Sol a linear Al
problem like you're using a sparse
Matrix Vector product something like
that how does that change what problems
you can and can't
solve
uh hello again I'm leean I think I will
mention one of the open problems uh in
my recent work so um consider the
problem of solving semi- defintive
program in streaming setting you have M
constraints each isan um symmetric
Matrix so in our work we show you can do
that in M square space so I think one of
the important open problems can you do
like n square plus m space which is like
the size of the Primal solution plus the
size of du solution
hey everyone uh my name is Nicole wine
I'm one of the long-term people here for
this semester after that I'll start as
an assistant professor at University of
Michigan my research interests are in
graph algorithms Dynamic algorithms
Computing distances and graphs and
things like
that hi everyone I'm sapida mahabadi um
I'm a senior researcher at Microsoft
research Redmon in the algorithms group
um I work on algorithms for Big Data
including streaming algorithms High
dimensional geometry sublinear
algorithms graph algorithms also
diversity fairness and privacy so also
if you're a student and you would like
to do internship in our group please
make sure to
apply hi I'm Dian nadell I'm professor
of macla and I'm speaking at 10:30 so
I'll keep mine very short and just pass
it
on hi I'm Casper green L I'm a professor
at ol University in Denmark I guess my
research interest are quite varied I
used to work data structures lower
bounds complexity and sketching as well
and I guess in recent years I'm
interested in particular in learning
theory and understanding classic
learning algs and improving
them hi I'm Miss haak I'm a pH student
here at Berkeley I work with galani and
Peter barlet upstairs um yeah I'm
interested in a little bit of learning
theory privacy and a bit of sketching
and streaming as
well
hello again my heart heart rate just
came down uh now it's racing again um
yeah as I just told you um I'm doing
dimensionality reduction uh I also do a
little bit of learning theory I heard
there was some learning people here so
maybe we could also talk about that yeah
thank
you hey Ian uh I'm being and I'm final
year P student at columia I work with
Crystal Papa Di and
uh some I work around topics around
machine learning and stral computer
science and I'm on job market this year
okay hello everyone uh I'm Ming coming
from uh ET zorich and my uh supervisor
is Rasmus King and my research interest
it is mostly uh like fine grind
complexity and faster algorithms for
linear programming and uh structure to
linear equation solvers yeah
thanks hi everyone I'm Andre grower I'm
a PhD student at Stanford and I'm
advised by Aron sford most of my work is
at the intersection of comor
optimization and compx optimization a
problem I've worked on a bunch I'm
excited about is a modular function
minimization um so it's the version of
sub modular function which is not NP
hard that the NP hard problem is the
maximization one and we actually have a
new paper that's going to be at Fox
about how to solve the case when the
minimizer is Parts much faster most of
the work for S function minimization the
C work for the general case us uses
cutting play methods and we're using a
lot of forer methods for our sparse
result and I think it's interesting to
check that out if you have Fox because
uh it kind of like does better in a
scenario in which cutting planes don't
do better and it could lead to improving
the runtime in the in the general case
thank
you hi I'm Arthur chumai from the
University of War I'm interested in Jing
algorithms approximation algorithms
randomized algorithms graph algorithms
Etc recently I have been working on some
problems in data streaming for
optimization problems in high dimensions
for some basic Dr graph problems so
that's
yeah I am Yan F I'm an assistant
professor at geia Tech I work on data
structures for linear algebra problems
with applications in like optimization
algorithms basically that upper Red Box
up there on the
screen um yeah nice to meet you
all hi everyone uh I'm Eric wearden I'm
an assistant professor at the University
of
Pennsylvania um I'm interested in
sublinear algorithms and algorithms
broadly um I guess I really like
geometric style questions and using
sketching you know to
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm Min priest at Lawrence
silmore National Laboratory uh my
research interests are in the
intersection of high performance
Computing and data science generally um
I do a lot of work on uh like geometric
metric geometric algorithms uh that are
both High dimensional and uh very large
in the um sample size uh as well as um
like graph algorithms particularly like
uh complex distributed memory graph
algorithms
um uh High dimensional and uh scalable
statistics um and a lot of different uh
science I support a lot of different
science
applications thank
you hi I'm Kent I'm coming from Purdue
but I'm here uh all semester and uh I
work on combinatory optimization
fast
sometimes hi I'm Rick of I'm a fifth
year PhD student here at Berkeley um I
work with Nik Shasta um I'm interested
in all sorts of stuff but most recently
I've been working on numerical linear
algebra hi uh my name is Hau I'm a
second year PhD student from MIT and my
advisor is Professor P indik my research
interest lies lies at the intersection
of algorithm design and machine learning
and I hope I can work on some
theoretical research which can be
potentially useful for the practice and
thank
you I'm an L from stonberg University uh
state of State University of New York on
Long Island I'm actually uh here for the
semester with the other program
concurrently here that's called logic
and algorithms
for uh database Theory and AI but my
official interest are actually in
programming language and compilers
especially high level languages that can
be optimized using general systematic
method to efficient algorithm so I'm
real algorithm especially even
distribute
algorithms hi uh I'm farad vadi I'm
coming from University Bergen in Norway
uh my research is parameterized
complexity hi I'm Moses chariker I'm
professor at Stanford before that I was
on the faculty at Princeton for many
years and even before that I was a grad
student at Stanford um one of the things
I worked on when I first started at
Princeton was the question of Dimension
reduction in L1 and we showed that um
the analog of Johnson L and Strauss for
L2 does not hold for
L1 um it' be great to actually get a
upper bound and onri upperbound for L1
it's a problem that I've come back to
I'd love to come back to actually but um
it' be great if someone got interested
and solve the
problem hi I'm Aur I'm a PhD student at
NYU and I'm advised by Chris MCO and I
mostly work on Fast algorithms for graph
problems and currently I've been working
on like um powers and limitations of
random Works to estimate igen values of
graphs hi so I'm Seer seeran I'm an
associate professor at University of
water as two months ago um so I
like my problems of Interest let's say
graph coloring matching set cover in no
particular order and I usually work on
sublinear algorithms and lower bounds
these years I've been very interested in
proving multipass graph streaming either
algorithms or lower
[Applause]
bounds hi I'm Peter McGregor I'm a post
at the University of Edinburgh um my
research interests are mostly in graph
Club clustering algorithms and in
particular trying to make them scale uh
and work in
practice hello I'm K from University of
idor so in the past I work on disputing
and Computing and randomized algorithms
so in recent years I work on different
kinds of graph classing and graph
specification
problems hi everyone I'm prti RoR I'm a
third-year PhD student at Stanford
advised by Malin Udell So lately I've
been thinking about how to use sketching
and stochastic optimization so I'm just
gonna be working on that some
more hello everyone my name is vami
Krishna putluru I'm a researcher at JP
Morgan AI research uh I did my PhD in
Matrix factorization and I got
introduced to sketching uh through David
Woodruff we have a bunch of work with
him and then uh lately I've been pulled
away a little bit more into the Bandit
world but I'm trying to get back to the
sketching
uh hello I'm I um I'm a PhD student at
the University of Toronto advised by
suant and uh my research interest is in
spectral graph Theory and linear algebra
algorithms and recas be working on
specification for dat
graphs I'm Mel torb I'm interested in
algorithms in general uh I have a pet
thing about hashing trying to make hash
functions that are implementable and yet
have all the theoretic or some of the
theoretical properties that we need like
in Johnson Linton Strauss all these
different things to actually make all
these theor results be implementable in
the real world with the theory
preserved hi I'm Valerie King I'm from
University of Victoria which is on
Vancouver Island which is between
Seattle and Vancouver and we're looking
for people to hire in theory we don't
don't care what area if you're good and
so just come and see me I do Dynamic
graph algorithms Byzantine agreement
Distributing Computing uh and any kind
of interesting thing that I can
find all right hi everyone my name is
rmos p I'm a professor at University of
Copenhagen where where Mel also is um
I'm interested in randomized algorithms
and data structures in general in
particular sketching and I really like
simple algorithms with non-trial
analysis
hi everyone my name is Elena Guk I'm a
second year PhD student at Princeton
advised by hung Yu um I'm most
interested in streaming and sketching in
general but recently I've been working
on adversarial robustness in the
streaming model um and hopefully proving
lower bounds for a more natural problem
um I'm also interested in the quantile
estimation problem for the relative
error
case hello everyone I'm anas opman and
I'm a postto uh working with chatra
induk at MIT and some of his students
who are like present here um so I have
like a right of interest but one of them
being those learning augmented
algorithms for instance
uh learning augmented frequency
estimation where you get some
predictions about what the heavy hit
hitters in a stream are s is going to
talk about some of that later I also
have an interest in
like in designing Hing schemes with
theoretical says what m talked
about hi everyone I'm Huen I'm at nor
Eastern University U my uh interest is
uh in optimization and uh more recently
I'm uh curious about um the use of
sketching to get algorithms with
differential privacy and also the use of
sketching in continuous
oration hi everyone my name is asand
deep I'm a final year PC student at MIT
I like Fast algorithms and also having
really tasty food so if you know if
either of those things interests you you
know I would love to hang
out hi everyone I'm Justin I already
told you I guess about my research
interest I also really like movies so if
you've seen a great or you know strange
or interesting movie recently come tell
me about that
too hi everyone my name is fatik uh I'm
a post here in statistics Atley um I
primarily work on like statistical
machine learning problems but recently
been interested in like proving
statistical properties for some mates
using random MRI and PR
prod3 hello my name is the vanov uh
another thing that I didn't mention in
my slides that one of my professors work
on defal privacy so I try to match defal
privacy private method is optimization
so if you want to talk about that I'm
here as
well hi Daniel lern I'm at postto at
Stanford in statistics working with
Emanuel candes and I am broadly
interested in the emergent properties of
humanistics that we apply in algorithms
including the implicit regularization of
sketching as I talked about today but
also other things like what's going on
with neural networks and why um for
models are when you apply them on under
distribution shifts their relative
rankings are
preserved hi everyone so Lena I'm one of
the co-organizers of the program so I'm
interested in algorithm design in
general and optimization and lately I've
been thinking a lot about gradient
descent algorithms
and and
[Applause]
I Thanks uh my name is tamas I um I work
at Google sometimes with the jalani
sometimes with he's going to talk
tomorrow I guess I started out in
sketching for linear algebra branched
into machine learning pied up some
differential privacy all kinds
of did uh we miss
anyone oh me too yeah sir I'll maybe
I'll go and then I'll pass it over um
okay so I'm galani um I'm I'm local here
at UC Berkeley I also spend part-time at
Google as well I work on streaming
algorithms dimensionality reduction and
lately I've been working a little bit
more on privacy especially in the local
[Applause]
model hi I'm Ali I at uh Toyota
technological Institute at Chicago I
work on streaming uh sublinear algorithm
learning augmented uh algorithm and also
algorithm uh
[Applause]
fairness so I think now that's everyone
um I guess our next talk is not for
another 15 minutes so maybe we could do
have a little break before that I just
want to mention I heard many people
mention open problems as part of their
introduction some of you who mentioned
open problems did email me your open
problem if you didn't uh please email me
we're having an open problem session as
the last session this afternoon I think
from 4 to 5:00 p.m even if you don't
email it to me you can still present
your open problem but that
[Applause]
make